.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
DAY 39 ESTIMATES OF HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS WITH GREEN CARDS THAT
ALLOW THEM INTO OUR COUNTRY AND
THOUSANDS OF AFGHAN ALLIES
ABANDONED BY JOE BIDEN BEHIND
ENEMY LINES LEFT TO BE TORTURED
AND 4 U.S. MARINES ARE STILL IN
THE HOSPITAL A MONTHS AFTER THE
TERRORIST ATTACK AT THE AIRPORT
IN KABUL.
JOE BIDEN CLAIMS HE TURNED THE
PAGE ON AFGHANISTAN.
TAKING A VICTORY LAP.
WHAT AN INSULTING THING TO SAY.
NOT LIFTING A FINGER TO HELP OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS HE ABANDONED.
THIS IS NOT REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
BRING THE AMERICANS HOME.
HE HASN'T MENTION THEM IN 22
DAYS.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
I WONDER IN THE FAMILIES OF
THOSE TRAPPED INSIDE AFGHANISTAN
IF THEY TURNED THE PAGE?
I WONDER IN THE FAMILIES OF THE
BRAVE SOLDIERS THAT DIED LAST
MONTH IN AFGHANISTAN, IF THEY
TURNED THE PAGE WHEN JOE COULD
HAVE EVACUATED EVERYBODY AND ALL
OF THE MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND
ALLIES AND FAMILIES BEFORE HE
ALLOWED THE TALIBAN ON THE MARCH
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING AND EARLY
SUMMER.
HE HAD FULL CONTROL.
I WONDER IN THE FAMILY OF THE
SEVEN CHILDREN KILLED IN BIDEN'S
BOTCHED DRONE ATTACK, I WONDER
IF THEY TURNED THE PAGE.
JOE BIDEN THINKS HE CAN SIMPLY
MOVE ON AND TURN THE PAGE AND
THE MEDIA MOB GIVES HIM A FREE
PASS.
JUST LIKE THEY DID ON THAT DRONE
STRIKE IN AFGHANISTAN.
JOE BIDEN KILLED TEN INNOCENTS
CIVILIANS AND HUMANITARIANS AND
SEVEN CHILDREN.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THE
DRONE ATTACK AGAINST ISIS-K
WON'T BE THE LAST.
>> MAYBE 8 OUT OF 10 TIMES WE
ARE HITTING THE WRONG TARGET.
WE HAVE KILLED THOUSANDS OF
CIVILIANS.
IT WOULD BE PAR FOR THE COURSE
IF THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT
COLLATERAL DAMAGE FROM A DRONE
STRIKE IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> DRONE STRIKES HAVE BEEN
A FEATURE OF THE 20 YEAR WAR ON
TERROR.
THOUSANDS RESULTED IN THOUSANDS
OF CIVILIAN CASUALTIES.
THIS HAS BEEN CHARACTERISTIC OF
THE U.S. MISSION OVERSEAS.
>> Sean: WHAT WOULD BE THE MEDIA
REACTION BE IN DONALD TRUMP
KILLED HUMANITARIANS AND
CHILDREN IN THE DRONE STRIKE
INSTEAD OF JOE BIDEN?
THE MEDIA WOULD BE HYSTERICAL.
EVEN DURING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
SUCCESSFUL DRONE STRIKE THAT
TOOK OUT THE WORLD'S BIGGEST
TERRORIST.
SOLEIMANI, RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEATHS OF COUNTLESS AMERICAN
SOLDIERS IF IRAQ AND ELSEWHERE.
EVEN DURING THAT SUCCESSFUL
STRIKE WITHOUT COLLATERAL
DAMAGE, THE MEDIA MOB, THEY WERE
OUTRAGED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DONALD TRUMP GAVE THEM WHAT
THEY WANTED BY KILLING
SOLEIMANI.
THEN THE OTHER ELEMENT ALL BETS
ARE OFF ON THE NUCLEAR CAPACITY
AND AMBITIONS.
>> IF THE AMERICANS OR TRUMP
THOUGHT TAKING OUT SOLEIMANI
IRAN WILL RECALCULATE ITS
POLICIES IN THE REGION, IT'S THE
OPPOSITE.
THEY WILL DOUBLE DOWN.
>> IN THE FIRST 24 HOURS BY
TAKING OUT SOLEIMANI, TRUMP MADE
THE SITUATION WORSE.
THAT'S DANGEROUS FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
>> HIS DECISION TO STRIKE
SOLEIMANI ENDANGERED U.S. TROOPS
AND EMBASSIES EVERYWHERE.
>> Sean: DONALD TRUMP COULD HAVE
FOLLOWED THE MODEL OF OBAMA AND
BIDEN AND SENT PLANES FULL OF
CASH TO BRIBE THEM, PLEASE BE
NICE TO US.
THEY SAY DOWN TO THE UNITED
STATES AND CHANT DEATH TO
AMERICA ANYWAY AND BURN OUR
FLAG.
2 YEARS LATER BIDEN DRONES AN
INNOCENT FAMILY AND 7 KIDS AND
THE JOURNALISTS BARELY JOHN.
-- YAWN.
THE MEDIA IS CORRUPT.
WE WITNESSED THE MEDIA.
JOE WAS IN THE MEDIA PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
THEY ALLOWED HIM TO HIDE IN HIS
BASEMENT FOR MONTHS.
THEY NEVER ASKED HIM TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
NOW BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY IS AN
ABJECT FAILURE.
HIS APPROVAL NUMBERS PLUMMETED
IN BATTLEGROUND STATES EVEN
ACCORDING TO FAKE NEWS CNN
SHOULD TERRIFY JOE BIDEN.
JOE'S POLL NUMBERS HAVE NEVER
BEEN LOWER.
INFLATION IS SKY ROCKETING.
GAS UP ABOUT $1.50 A GALLON
SINCE HE BECAME PRESIDENT ON
JANUARY 20th.
WE ARE PAYING MORE FOR
EVERYTHING WE BUY.
MORE TO HEAT AND COOL OUR HOMES.
AFTER SHUTTERING PIPE LINES AT
HOME HE IS ASKING OPEC TO
PRODUCE MORIL?
THEY TURNED HIM DOWN.
COVID IS SPREADING FASTER THAN
AT ANY POINT UNDER TRUMP.
BIDEN IS RATIONING MONOCLONALS
ANTIBODIES TREATMENTS TO HURT
THE RED STATES GOVERNORS.
BIDEN NEVER MENTIONED
MONOCLONALS ANTIBODIES UNTIL
A WEEK AGO.
FRANCE RECALLED THEIR AMBASSADOR
AND ISRAEL IS THREATENING TO DO
THE SAME.
EVERY ENEMY AROUND THE WORLD IS
EMBOLDENED AND CHINA'S THREATS
GO WORSE BY THE DAY.
THE SOUTHERN BORDER A START.
-- DISASTER.
FOR 7 STRAIGHT MONTHS JOE AND
KAMALA HARRIS TWIDDLED THEIR
THUMBS.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" WENT TO
TEXAS AND ASKED MIGRANTS WHY
THEY WERE COMING TO THE BORDER?
THEY DECIDED TO RISK EVERYTHING
AFTER HEARING FROM FRIENDS AND
RELATIVES AND SMUGGLERS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WOULD LET
THEM IN.
JOE AND KAMALA HARRIS, WE DID
NOT FORGET.
THE ROOT CAUSE OF MASS
MIGRATION.
LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
YOU INVITED THIS MESS.
YOU SEE THE IMAGES OF MIGRANTS
CAMPED OUT UNDER THIS BRIDGE.
11,000 IN TEXAS.
THEY ARE NOW BEING LET INTO OUR
COUNTRY BY THE THOUSANDS WITHOUT
A SIMPLE COVID TEST.
NO VACCINE MANDATE.
SHODDY VETTING.
VERY LITTLE PAPERWORK.
PROCESS AND RELEASE.
THAT'S THE BIDEN IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
COME INTO THE UNITED STATES ON
A PROMISE THEY WILL SHOW UP FOR
A FUTURE COURT DATES.
ALMOST NONE EVER SHOW UP.
THIS WEEK FOX NEWS.COM FOLLOWED
THE MIGRANTS AFTER THEY WERE
PROCESSED AT THE BORDER AND PUT
ON A BUS HEADED TO DALLAS.
THEY ARE DISPERSED WITHOUT COVID
TESTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND NO
VACCINE MANDATES EAR.
-- EITHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: FREE FOOD AND
TRANSPORTATION AND NO COVID TEST
AND NO VACCINE MANDATE.
THE MIGRANTS WHO VIOLATED OUR
LAWS AND DID NOT RESPECT OUR
SOVEREIGNTY AND BORDERS.
WITH THE HELP OF JOE BIDEN HE IS
AIDING AND ABETTING.
THEY ARE DISPERSED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS UNWILLING
TO SAY HOW MANY.
BUT WE KNOW THESE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS HAVE NOT BEEN VETTED
LIKE THOSE WHO IMMIGRATE HERE
LEGAL.
I SUPPORT LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
SOME THE HAITIANS MIGRANTS HAVE
BEEN VIOLENT.
ONE GROUP ATTACKED U.S. PILOTS
AND ASSAULTED I.C.E. OFFICERS ON
A FLIGHT AND ANOTHER TOOK OVER
A DHS BUS AND FLED THE SEASON
BEFORE THEY WERE APPREHENDED AND
HHS DOCUMENTS SHOW IN FEBRUARY
THERE WERE DOZENS OF INCIDENTS
OF SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL ABUSE OF
THE UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT
CHILDREN JOE PUT IN CAGES.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT IS
INVESTING $3 BILLION STATE OF
TEXAS DOLLARS.
CALLED UP THE GUARD IN HIS STATE
TO THE BORDER EVEN FORMING
A MILE LONG MAKESHIFT BORDER
WALL WITH A FLEET OF VEHICLES.
THAT'S HOW DESPERATE HE IS
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN IS AIDING AND
ABETTING THE WHOLE PROCESS.
THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH TEXAS CAN
DO.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
RELEASING MIGRANTS INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE TOTAL JURISDICTION.
BIDEN IS NOT ONLY IGNORING THE
LAWS OF THIS COUNTRY.
HE IS AIDING AND ABETTING THE
LAW BREAKING.
DONALD TRUMP HAD THIS UNDER
COMPLETE CONTROL AND JOE
ABANDONED EVERYTHING THAT WAS
WORKING.
WE GOT TO A GIVE YEAR LOW OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY.
A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AND
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
I SUPPORT LEGAL IMMIGRATION WITH
CHECKS AND VETTING TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE RADICAL
ASSOCIATIONS.
PROOF YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF
FINANCIALLY AND IN THE MIDDLE OF
A PANDEMIC WE NEED TO KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE COVID-19 OR ANY OTHER
DISEASE.
ALL OF THIS COULD BE RESOLVED IF
JOE BIDEN WOULD TELL MIGRANTS
NOT TO COME AND END PROCESS AND
RELEASE AND FINISH THE WALL
DONALD TRUMP WAS BUILDING.
BRING BACK THE STAY IN MEXICO
POLICY AND ENFORCE THE LAW.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE SOCIALIST BASE DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN BORDERS OR IN U.S.
SOVEREIGNTY OR IN PROPERTY
RIGHTS OR THE CONSTITUTION OR
THE RULE OF LAW.
DEMOCRATS EVEN TRYING TO PUSH
THROUGH THEIR AMNESTY USING
A PROCESS RATHER THAN CHANGING
THE LAW.
THAT $3.5-TRILLION NEW GREEN
CARD.
AND ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS
THE REAL SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
SHE IS UPSET ABOUT A REPORT THAT
HAITIANS MIGRANTS COULD BE HELD
AT A FACILITY IN GITMO.
MAXINE WATERS CALLS BIDEN'S
TREATMENT OF THE HAITIANS
MIGRANTS WORSE THAN SLAVERY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I AM UNHAPPY AND I AM NOT
JUST UNHAPPY WITH THE COWBOYS
WHO WERE RUNNING DOWN HAITIANS
AND USING THEIR REINS TO WHIP
THEM.
I AM UNHAPPY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE ARE FOLLOWING THE TRUMP
POLICY.
HE IS THE ONE THAT DOES NOT
FOLLOW THE CONSTITUTION AND
WOULD NOT ALLOW THOSE SEEKING
REFUGE TO PETITION TO GET INTO
THE COUNTRY.
WHAT THE HELL ARE WE DOING HERE?
WHAT WE WITNESSED TAKES US BACK
HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
WHAT WE WITNESSED WAS WORSE THAN
WHAT WE WITNESSED IN SLAVERY.
>> Sean: TRUMP HAS BEEN OUT OF
OFFICE FOR 7 MONTHS.
AOC AND THE RADICAL SQUAD HOLD
ALL THE CARDS AND NANCY PELOSI
IS TERRIFIED OF THEM.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PASS THIS N